The values of x that satisfy this inequality are from negative 5 halves to
positive 3. Great work if you found this interval. As usual, we begin by
finding the 0s for this quadratic equation. We set this quadratic expression
equal to 0, and then factor it, and set each factor equal to 0. So we'll have
2x plus 5 equal 0 and x minus 3 equals 0. When we solve for the values of x, we
see that x can equal negative 5 halves or x can equal 3. We'll use the values
of negative 5 halves in positive 3 to set up our three intervals on our number
line. These two values make this left side of our inequality equal to 0. So, we
want to test other values, so that way, this left-hand side is less than 0. If
we let x equal negative 5 in interval I, we get the statement 40 is less than
0. We know this is not true, so this interval or this region is out. No values
in here satisfy our inequality. For the second interval, we'll test the value
of 0, since that's in between negative 5 halves and positive 3. If x equals 0,
we plug it in and we get the statement that negative 15 is less than 0. Well,
this is true, so this part is part of the solution set. And finally, for our
third interval, we just need to test a number greater than 3. If I let x equal
5, I get the statement 30 is less than 0. This is not true, so again, this part
is out of my solution set. These are the only values that make the inequality
true. We use parentheses at negative 5 halves and positive 3, since we can't
equal 0. We must be less than 0. Again, fantastic work if you got most of that
solution correct. These are tough.